[موسيقى]
مع
شقيت لما خشوا خشوا على الاماره بيزعقوا
هم لهم فجروا البواب
وخشوا فجروا البباب اللي تحتنا احنا على
السالس ساكنين قلنا رحنا فتحنا الباب وضوي
الضو بالعالم بضب وخش من هان بنقول له يا
عمي مدنيين وشافنا نساوين ورجال وشباب
وهات اللي يقنع اول واحد لطشوه جوز اختي
ابو حمده طخو بقوله مدنيين وشايفه ضو يعني
ضا عالي جمعوا
الرجال والنسوان
بشقه الرجال
تحوه وبعد هيك قالوا لنسوان ضلكم في
الغربي امان لكم اضرب قذائف دبابه يوم
الجمعه حوط حوط حوط حوط وخشوا علينا زي
الغلال وهي النتيجه اكثر من 18 شهيد
اولادي جزن بناتي زانهم اولادهم كلهم
صفوهم تصفيه بدم بارد قتل عمد قتل عمد
اعدام بدون اي مقاومه ب قهم مدنيين احنا
مدنيين والله يجوز بنت مسكين قاعد على
الكنبايه قاعد رفع ايديه قالله مدني صفاه
اي قال لسه لقيت قعدته لقيت قعدته مش
عارفي يروح نجيبه مش عارفين نروح نجيبهم
ندفنهم يعني خشوا علينا في العماره وطلعوا
بيت بيت يخشوا وطفوا فيها ويعربد نزلوا
بنتي غصب عنها وابنها طلع مش عارفينها وين
واخذوا جوزي وا وجوز بنتي وولاد شباب هذا
في الدور الاول ظلهم يطلعوا كل دور بدوره
اخذوا الجيران لمونا احنا كل الستات لمونا
احنا حطونا في اوضه و واخذوا الرجال كلهم
اول ما فاتوا عندي على السادس نزلوا طخ
نسيبي وابنه على المطرح في نفس الشقه
اعدام اعدام ايش عملوا فيهم بالضبط طخ على
طول يعني احنا فاتحين الباب فاتوا عنا و
لهم احنا مدنيين وضين الضو قاعدين نزلوا
طخ طخ طخ طخ طخ اثنين وكله طخ في الحيطان
واحنا الستات شدونا من شعرنا ونزلنا وكل
الشباب جمعوهم اخذوهم سلاحهم عريانين وعلى
البسطه خلوهم مكفيين بعدين احنا جمعونا
كلنا احنا والجيران وكل عائلتي انا كمان
في في اوضه غربيه كده في الدور الرابع
وخلونا خلونا شوف فتشونا وخلونا نرفع عن
شعرنا بعدين نلبس يعني بعدين نزلوا الشباب
من من فوق عريانين عدموهم اعدام ادام
مباشر وبعدين قال له اجا الامر فنزل هو
وقذفه على الستات كلهم في في الاوضه في
صاب وبناتي وجيران وفي طفله ظن استشهدت
كمان حتى الصغار لا يسلم ولا واحد من
الصغار سلم كلهم ضربوهم كسروهم هي موجودين
في المستشفى روحوا
[موسيقى]
شوفوهم
راس بعد ما وقفونا ثلاث قذائف رموا على
راسنا ورصاص قليه قليه كفهم مش هيك اجوا
عنا على الصالون طخو طخ طخ طخ انا في ايدي
رصاصه بنتي في راسها رصاصه ابني بطل يشوف
بنتي الصغيره استشهدت جوزي قعد كل بنات
اصابات رجل بنتي كلها مفتوحه فيش لحم
ايدها مكسوره بنتي كل جسمها شضايا انا من
امبارح الساعه خه وانا بنزف كل
جسمي